the landscape of massively multiplayer
RPGs has evolved over the last few years
and the audience is followed suit where
we were once used to paying subscription
fees for this type of content
expectations have changed but some
people involved with creating the latest
MMO still think that subscriptions have
a place in the industry today we asked
them for their thoughts on the matter
and why they think the model can still
be relevant
I I don't think that you could take
subscriptions and just sort of liberally
apply it all games and say well these
guys didn't do it well they're there for
it doesn't work anymore
I think each game is unique there have
certainly been examples in recent past
of and on those that try to do a
subscription and they didn't succeed I
think you could have a reasonable
argument amongst reasonable people as to
whether or not the problem in that case
was the subscription or the game and
what I've offered and what it would
whether it was worth the subscription if
we succeed and we're releasing stuff
that people make people say this is
worth my money I got more out of this
fifteen dollars in terms of what I'm
getting to do in this game than I would
have if I had applied that towards any
other game or anything else so it's a
value proposition we feel pretty strong
about the support that we're gonna have
for the game of what you're gonna get
for those dollars and ultimately we
think fans are going to agree
appreciating it's not for everybody but
no game is really for everybody if if
this is the kind of game that you want
to play and you're willing to put down
subscription money then it's an option
if you're straight-up not willing to pay
a subscription then we recognize that
you're not gonna play it but we're not
trying to make a game that like
everybody who plays games will
automatically buy there is a version of
this what we could have said we're not
going to charge a subscription and we
are going to allocate whatever
percentage of the team to make stuff
that we can we can afford a support
based on the base sale of the game but
we decided that's not the that's not
what we want to do like that just seems
like a lesser game and we're not gonna
make a lesser game that that might be
more palatable we want to do the version
of the thing that we think is the best
game and the coolest experience in
contrast MMO wildstar from carbine
studios runs a slightly different
subscription model gametime consumes a
resource named cred which can be
purchased using real world money or in
the game using in-game gold this means
more time you spend playing the game and
gathering gold the more you can extend
your time to play the game to gather
more gold
our intention with cred is that as we
look to the market it seems like the
best way to get some key things that we
wanted firstly obviously people want to
play for free if we could support that
while being responsible financially we
wanted to secondly some folks want to
buy in-game goods for cash they have
extra money they want to put that to
work for them in the game because maybe
they don't have the time to go in and
play for tons of hours we looked at
lineage for instance for every dollar
people paid us in subscriptions the size
of the Korean eBay market said that
about five dollars was spent by other
players buying weapons and castles this
meant that we might make 200 million
dollars on the game but people were
paying over a billion for instance
showing that there was a market there so
the joy of the model is it pairs these
people person B by his cred and trades
it safely on the commodities exchange no
scamming no hacking person Abe buys it
for gold and both players are happy win
and win carbine studios described the
value of the game is being in line with
what players paid for in subscriptions
our intention has been to be as
aggressive with content drops as was
feasible while also supporting a massive
live game we have multiple teams working
on drops as we speak
entire zones worth of quest path and
event content will be released
throughout the year we feel that this
gives us an edge in the MMO space
because we are providing the customer
with the most value not to mention the
most fun for their subscription
final fantasy 14 a realm reborn launched
a PC PlayStation 3 and PlayStation 4
less than 12 months ago like in the
older scrolls online its users pay a
subscription fee but why was this the
best model to go with director and
producer Naoki Ishida explains
it all comes down to the market and the
requirement from the knees from the
players and them are took in a market
currently we are running to a
subscription business model and I think
it's going too smoothly so there's no
immediate plan that you to switch to a
free-to-play model or anything like that
and that being said we are considering
introducing a free trial system which
will allow players to try out the game
for approximately maybe around ten days
for free and if they like it they can
peruse the retail version that kind of
idea we definitely investigated at the
moment I'm not saying that we have to
have the subscription model so maybe in
the future of time war car it all comes
down to if we receive enough but a lot
of requesting players and what we want
to focus in the future but they're the
most important thing is to have the
enjoyable great game and otherwise only
their model would be successful despite
a precedent set by other MMOs switching
to a free-to-play model these games have
managed to make subscriptions work what
do you think could these be the last
major MMOs to launch with a subscription
fee could wildstar be onto something
with players able to pay for time using
in-game currency let us know your
thoughts in the comments below